I'm very, very proud of it, finally,
what we did for brecht, including
everything here all the time, so I told my friends that I'm
the
writer and supported the supervisors
, but actually had
no idea what I was doing and
now it's the first time
actually what was translated into hebrew
my friends and
family were able to read what i actually
do the question always comes up: is that what
you want here most israelis find it very
difficult to understand why
you want to be here when you could legally live in berlin
and i actually
have the feeling that as a light jew
, a lot of people find him great here because i think he were
i jewish now that would fit for them as some kind of grid
the
fact that it is a conscious
decision for me that i am here
simply because  I think it's great here
I think it's a lot nice I
honestly think it kind of flatters you too